the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of thrones season
8 video all right my friends in this
video i want to show you what one of the
game of thrones actors had to say about
the final season of the show during one
of his recent interviews now if you're
like me i think you will find this to be
not only interesting but mostly annoying
because i think it's another attempt at
dismissing at least some of the fans
criticism of game of thrones season 8.
let's have a look at the new article so
i can show you what mr dinklage said
about the final season of game of
thrones the headline reads dinklage says
game of thrones fans were upset about
the finale because they wanted the white
characters to ride off into the sunset
he is basically saying that fans were
only upset because john and danny did
not sit on the iron throne together
that's right he did not hold back in a
recent interview with the new york times
when it was brought up that game of
thrones fans were let down by the show's
finale he also said by the way it's
fiction he added with a laugh there's
dragons in it move on alright now i also
want to give some of my own thoughts on
what he said so far
first off let me just say this i am a
massive fan of the actor not only do i
think he brilliantly brought tyrion
lannister to life on the screen but he
also delivered some of the greatest
scenes in game of thrones i think it's
safe to say that dinklage was one of the
best actors on the show i think he
helped make tyrion one of the most
beloved characters in a cast that was
full of dozens of great actors and
actresses now with that out of the way i
also want to say that i completely
disagree with what he said in the
interview for him to say that fans were
only upset with the finale because the
gorgeous white characters weren't riding
off into the sunset together is simply
false if you go back and watch all of my
older videos you will see that i said
jon snow will never want the iron throne
which made sense because that's who he
was as a character he was never in it
for the iron throne so we would have
been foolish to think that's where he
would have ended now dany on the other
hand has a different story
as we all know daenerys was focused on
taking back king's landing as well as
the iron throne but fans were not angry
just because she didn't get it daenerys
fans were furious because of who her
character became in such a short span of
episodes she basically became adolf
hitler by the end of the series shocking
millions of fans because it seemed to
happen so suddenly they're not angry
because john and danny weren't holding
hands overlooking king's landing in the
end let us also not forget what happened
to the night king now for me this was
the most upsetting and it wasn't only
because zarya stark was the one who
defeated the night king if you have seen
my videos then you know why i think it
was a bad idea to have arya stop the
night king however the other thing that
was so upsetting about this was the fact
that the night king and his army were
defeated almost immediately after they
made it through the wall as you all know
this was something they were building up
since the very first episode of the very
first season then when the night king
finally moves south he's defeated by
someone who didn't even know he existed
before the final season you want to know
what else made a lot of us fans upset
about the final season jaime and cersei
lannister for one we were extremely
unsatisfied with how they died not only
that but i was also heartbroken when i
heard jaime say he never cared about
saving everyone in king's landing it was
already bad enough that he ran back to
cersei but by him saying this it ruins
that amazing scene he had with brienne
when they were bathing in season 3. now
don't even get me started on what
happened in dorne or what happened with
arya stark when she was in braavos
saying that the fans were only angry
because john and danny weren't sitting
on the iron throne is so dismissive our
frustration with the final season goes
way deeper than just this do i even need
to mention how euron greyjoy's character
was handled or how the golden company
was dismantled in seconds i mean the
list of criticisms could go on and on
but i want to go over some of the other
things that he said in the interview
let's go back to when he said by the way
it's fiction there's dragons in it move
on
now just because there were dragons in
the show doesn't mean we should ignore
every mistake the writers made again i
can only speak for myself here but game
of thrones wasn't just some dumb show
that had dragons for me it was much more
than that game of thrones was
groundbreaking in so many ways and in
fact i think it redefined fantasy in a
way that had never been seen on
television before game of thrones had a
vast array of fascinating and complex
characters that blurred the lines of
good and evil even though the show did
have dragons and magic the relationships
the characters had with one another made
them feel real
all of us who did love the show
immediately identified and connected
with a number of different characters
and this made me care about them more
than any other character from different
shows or movies i had ever seen before
everyone else who worked behind the
scenes helped make this show and
universe feel realistic the set
designers the makeup artists the costume
designers the incredible music and so on
and so forth
let's see what else mr dinklage had to
say he said yeah was called game of
thrones but at the end the whole
dialogue when fans would approach me on
the street was who's gonna be on the
throne i don't know why that was their
takeaway because the show was really
more than that dinklage said that one of
his favorite moments from the finale was
when daenerys targaryen's dragon burned
the iron throne because it sort of just
killed that whole conversation which is
really irreverent and kind of brilliant
on behalf of the show's creators he said
shut up it's not about that dinklage
added referencing david benioff and d.b
weiss they constantly did that where you
thought one thing and they delivered
another he said everybody had their own
stories going on while watching that
show but nobody's was as good as what
the show delivered i think
wow he actually thinks no one could have
written it better than what david and
dan did
well once again i disagree
and i would bet that he feels somewhat
different as well but he doesn't want to
go against hbo because i'm sure he would
love to work there again he also said
that he felt audiences were angry about
how the show ended because the show was
simply coming to an end in general
we were going off the air and they
didn't know what to do with their
sundays anymore they wanted more so they
backlashed about that
well my friend we were not the only ones
who wanted more
why is it ending
i don't know ask dave and dan when they
come through um we could have gone to
11 12 13 seasons but uh they i guess
they wanted a life
you wanted it to keep going
well it you know if you've read my
novels
you know there was enough material for
for more seasons they made certain cuts
but but that's fine we have five other
shows five prequels in development
that are based on other periods in the
history of westeros some of them
just a hundred years before game of
thrones some of them five thousand years
before game of thrones
[Music]
[Music]
so
you